you're live now chairman
good morning and welcome to this special
virtual meeting of the overview and
scrutiny committee
my name is councillor o'donnell and i'm
the chairman for this meeting
you will have been provided with the
council's etiquette for virtual meetings
in advance of this meeting
however to reiterate the main points
please ensure your device is fully
charged or is charging
please mute microphones when not
speaking please indicate in the chat bar
if you wish to speak
when invited to address the committee
please ensure your microphone is
switched on
and switch off immediately once you have
finished
please ensure you have switched off or
to silent any other devices you have
that may interrupt the proceedings
if any members encounters it problems
causing them to drop out of the virtual
meeting
they should use best endeavors to rejoin
as quickly as possible
should the member be unable to rejoin
the meeting they will be deemed to have
left the meeting
at that point and the meeting will
continue provided it remains corrupt
the number to call should you experience
any it problems is the it help desk
the number will be put in the chat
function please note that the meeting is
being broadcast live and that members of
the public are able to view the
proceedings
i can confirm that checks have been made
to ensure that all members of the
committee are in attendance
and have confirmed that they can see and
hear the proceedings
also present online with me are the
following officers
scrutiny support officer justin long
democratic services officer
liz davorska and head of regulatory
services robert weeks
so moving on to item one on the agenda
liz do we have any apologies
none received chairman although i
believe councillor crump will be joining
us shortly
thank you i now invite members and
officers to make any declarations of
interest to the meeting
so given the subject matter we're
discussing i'm going to declare that i'm
a candidate in the upcoming county
council elections
none of us have declared yet whether
we're standing as candidates
um because we're not uh we've not signed
yet so we
are okay thank you councillor junaid for
bringing that to my attention
so moving then on to item three
chairman's brief as members will see
there is only one item on the agenda
today
um so councilor mills did you have your
hand raised
you're on mute counseling so sorry madam
chairman yes i'm i'll be standing as a
counter council candidate to the next uh
may elections madam chairman
authority clear that thank you thank you
very much councilman
um so moving on to item three channels
um the only point i wanted to make
before we get
in to the agenda is to alert members to
the report on call-in arrangements that
is going to cancel next week
the report presents options to revert to
the pre-precautions and
consider making permanent the
restriction of call-in to key decisions
i would urge members to study the report
and consider itself
implications for our work we should as
an organization be working towards
pre-decision scrutiny
and i would hope to keep calling to a
minimum
and would ask that key decisions
criteria is regularly reviewed
so moving on to item number four working
together with district council
as members will recall we were unhappy
that this report came to us
too late to consider at our last meeting
we have therefore arranged this special
meeting to consider the cabinet report
on the principle of further integration
including a potential full merger
with warwick district council thoughts
from our committee can then be fed into
the council meeting
next week with us today we have the
leader of the council councillor tony
jefferson
and chief executive david buckland and
we welcome them both
i want to get through as many questions
as possible however to begin i wanted to
invite
both mr buckland and councillor
jefferson to make any introductory
remarks and please continue to put your
um
questions in the chat
so mr buckland or councillor jefferson
who would like to open i
would be polite i was going to wait for
tony
thanks dude sorry can i also mention
that um tony perks is here as well
fine if i just pick up then
some of the background to why we are
considering the principle
of merging with warwick
it became quite obvious about 18 months
ago
that uh local government was under
tremendous financial pressure
as it happens the warwick district
council
and ourselves had a number of senior
management vacancies
uh the more andrew day and i talked
the more it seemed a good idea to
explore
the potential for working much closer
together
uh what you've also got to remember is
that in the background
while this was going on there was muted
a white paper on local government
reorganization
uh that would have pushed an awful lot
of changes into the local government
scene
it will probably have meant the creation
of
a great number of unitary councils
in parallel as we were talking about
this
uh warwickshire county council
began to put together a proposal for a
single
warwickshire unitary that caused
us to accelerate our thinking and
accelerate our
discussing and uh
doing background work on the merger
and i think what comes out of all this
is one very clear
point the district councils
the districts and borough councils in
warwickshire are going to disappear
warwickshire county council have already
made a submission
to the department uh for
a single warwickshire unitary
that is now on the table it's with the
department
so that if at the end of the day we do
not
merge with warwick and if the other
three boroughs do not get together
there will almost certainly be
a single warwickshire unitary council
that means there is an inevitability in
my view
that all the districts and boroughs in
warwickshire
will disappear now if you look
at the financial implications of the
proposed merger
they are in the budget already and the
savings there
are essential to ensuring we have a
sustainable budget
over the period of the medium-term
financial strategy
and i'm sure mr brookland uh
can elaborate on that if needed
so at the moment we are at the early
stages
and we have done a lot of work
which demonstrates that actually on
many many factors emerging between
warwick
and stratford is a good thing and you
all heard the presentation last night
from deloitte
there are a great many advantages in us
getting together
and i think at the back of members minds
they need to keep one thing
very very clear stratfor district
council is going to disappear
and the choice facing us is between
in essence being one of two in other
words getting together
with warwick or being one of six
if we end up with a single warwickshire
unitary
so that's the big picture background
life is not going to stay the same
there is absolutely no point pretending
it is
it really isn't now i know there are an
awful lot of issues in detail
and i know that one of the main issues
raised last night was about council tax
and i think david buckland has a
presentation that may well help
explain some of the issues there
so um over to you
madam chair can i come in as
as well please chad just to give a
little bit of context about
what is being asked of council next week
and what isn't being asked so
as you know back in july last year there
was this
uh statement issued by the two leaders
of bargain strike
district council to commit to work more
closely together and that was followed
then by the report to
cabinet council which started the
integration of your management team so
your management teams have
very much started the integration now
when we have as from the first of march
we'll have five
joint heads of service between two local
authorities and that that also
instigated the start of the uh
joint work in relation to the the local
plan
what has been commissioned from delights
is an independent piece of work from
deloitte's
looking at the merits and disadvantages
of
potentially coming together as a merged
to authorities and that they'll stand
as an independent piece of evidence that
was considered last night and and i do
thank james
for such a thorough briefing of the um
of their piece of work i i do want to be
clear that what council are being asked
to do on the 22nd is to endorse
the vision of working together to become
effectively one authority by
2024 but there will be further reports
and further work undertaken to support
that work
and that will then come back for a
further council decision before any
submission is made to central government
so before we as an authority made
any approaches to government to say that
this is what we want to do formally
there would be an opportunity for a huge
amount of additional work a huge amount
of consultation
looking at the implementation program
which was being
suggested within the recommendations
before
any final decision by council so i just
wanted to make it clear that
on monday you're not being asked for a
final this is going to be a submission
central government
being prompted by that decision it's
just a direction of travel if you like
it
at this stage before any further
decisions are council
now i'm i'm very happy tony says the
main issue that i thought was coming out
of the presentation
last night was around constant
harmonization and share with your
and said at some point point i'd like to
just run through a brief presentation
that i put together to hopefully
try and explain that issue in a bit more
depth
thank you um david that's that's really
helpful i think if i can also just
welcome to the meeting george hill who
is our
head of resources and transformation and
also tony parks is our deputy chief
executive
welcome and thank you so much for taking
the time to join us on this extra
meeting
david would you like to run through your
presentation now around council taxes
there are some questions around that
um and then we can go into questions
overall if that's all right
okay i will i'll inevitably say i've
never shared my screen during a live
event so i hope this is going to work
and justin will you
i hope not your head if you think it's
going to work if i haven't heard
if it's not 100 let's let's see what
happens um
right
everybody see my screen can you just
check that yes
okay so as i say last night at the
presentation that james provided it
it seemed that the main line of
questioning related to tax harmonization
and and this is the basis that when
formed
any council area has to have the same
level of council tax
levied across the whole of that council
tax that council area
and and this is what we've seen in some
community governance reviews we've
already had within
the stratfor district plaintiffs like
voter certain henley however
weakly when parishes come together then
the expectation there is that there's a
consistent level of council tax across
that area
that would be exactly the same with two
local authority districts joining
together
that that new count that new area would
have to have a common level of council
tax
now currently the report and quite
rightly identified this as an issue
and it also identified that there are
differences in the proposed level of
council tax
the figures that are contained within
the report relate to the current
2021 council tax figures but of course
as we all near
full councils next week we've now got
the proposed level of council tax for
21 22 so the purposes of this
presentation
i've incorporated them into this report
stratford as you'll be aware is
proposing a five pounds increase in
council tax
that would take out band d figure to 149
pounds
12 and wike are also considering a five
pound
increase that would take their accounts
taxpayer 176 pounds 86.
the difference between the two is 27
pounds 74.
now before before i go on it would be
for the future
council if that was formed to make a
decision as to
what approach they took to council tax
harmonization so we are
talking about something well into the
future but it is an issue that at least
needed to be identified as a potential
issue as in relation to merging now the
report itself identifies three
potential ways forward in relation to
cancer tax harmonization
um the first one
and i've illustrated this just just
remembers benefits so they could see
how that would work would be that
stratford-unhaven continues to increase
its council tax by five pounds a year
and warwick district council freezes
their council tax
under that approach we don't get
harmonized we don't get to a common
figure
until the year 27-28 so you'll see that
stratford's figure goes from 149 to 154
in five pound increments which is the
current maximum permissible
for district councils and white district
council freezes
their level of council tax the issue for
that
for warwick district council up until
the point the merger
would be that they would be losing
council tax income that they could
otherwise have levied and therefore
that does start to detract some of the
savings
which would be achieved by by the merger
the second option is for a much quicker
harmonization
so in under this model again stratfor
district council increases their council
tax by five pounds a year
and then on the fourth year which is the
assumed year of
inception of the new authority you would
then harmonize
at the higher level roy district council
freezing at 176 pounds
86 for the duration up until that merger
again
and the third option just for clarity
was
that we both continue with five pound a
year increases or the maximum
permissible increases in council tax
and that at the point of merger then a
weighted average
of the council taxes is taken which
doesn't
therefore cost any more across the piece
um but you do then get that standard
level of council tax
issue so that that would show stratfor
figure would
move from 149 pounds to 12 pence now
potentially 178 pounds or they're there
bounced by 24.5
so they're the three options identified
within the report there will be further
options that could be considered
for this but but for the purposes of the
report they were the three that were
considered
reference was also made last night to
the wider local government review
and one of the issues that was raised in
the county council report
in relation to harmonization but not
explored in any depth whatsoever
was the issue about the different levels
of council tax across the wider world
share area
so the difference between stratford and
warwick's uh council tax you'll see from
this slide
if the proposed increases go through
next week is that still like 27 pounds
bigger
but the big difference is the difference
between stratfor district 149 pounds
and none eaten in bedworth which is
nearly at 245 pounds
so that would be an issue that should
widely local government review come
about for a unitary violence shift
would need to be considered about the
council the impact on structural naval
district council taxpayers at that point
because we would then be nearly 100
pounds beneath
that the highest level at malignant
bedwar
and even if you look to their a
harmonized average across a piece it
would be much higher
than the figure four for white at moment
at 276 pounds
so that that was just to try and explain
the cancer tax harmonization figure
i do have one further a couple of
further slides if that's okay
i'm just just sorry chairman um
the first one and i i i must remind
the osc this is the proposed medium term
financial plan
as per the the cabinet decision on the
18th of
january and is being reported to the
council for decision
next week and that shows that our
reserves over the next five years
even with the savings assumed from
working with white district council
go from around seven and a half million
pounds at the end of
2122 to around 2.7 million which is
just above the the minimum that our
section 151 officer
george hill says we should maintain as a
local authority
i for illustrative purposes without the
po
the proposals which have been included
within the budget
from working with oil district council
more closely
those reserves we we're not assuming any
savings whatsoever in 2012
but by the time we get to the end of the
mtfp period
in 2526 there's one and a quarter
million pounds worth of recurring
savings included in that year
without those savings we would be in a
deficit position with the reserves of
around 420 000
but that is in no way a political point
i just wanted to make the
the point for um illicit purposes that
there is a lot
of additional savings included in the
budget based on the working with why
and without those proposals they would
have to be identified from other sources
that's just to state the fact chairman
so i'm happy to take any questions on
particularly the council tax issue first
if that's something that your committee
wants to explore
thank you so much um david that's really
helpful and you won't be surprised at
all there is a flurry of questions
around council tax
so i'm going to start initially with
councillor fitter then we have a
question from councillor crump
then councillor juned and then
councillor frankly
cool thank you good morning david
so um i i understand that um with this
merger the public pound
will benefit um services will be a lot
more efficient
etcetera but thinking about the pockets
of residents
in distracted pontiavan is it fair that
residents are now going to have to be
paying more for their services
um to merge with warwick district
council and with the deloitte
report would we not consider a fourth
option
where harmonization goes the other way
just being
optimistic is that not something that we
could consider where warwick
levels are ambitious towards coming down
to stratford's
levels okay if i can respond to that
point of chair
and i'm
you can come in with some further detail
if necessary of course
the option could be to harmonize at the
lower level that the stratfor made in
district council current level of
council tax
and as i said earlier that will be a
decision for any future council to make
the dis benefit of harmonizing at the
lower level is that
all of the savings the 4.6 million
pounds worth of recurring savings
which delivers identified in the report
could be possible by joining together
would be lost by that lower council tax
yield that would be generated across the
the wider south last year
because if you harmonize at the lowest
level you're not effectively
recovering the council tax which is
currently being levied within the wild
district council area
at that higher rate so that would go
significantly
against the the level of savings i think
tony mentioned it within the the
introduction
it's inevitable that we will be
receiving less government support
as we move forward we've already been on
notice that
um there is a spending review coming and
that spending review has now been
delayed three times it's been played
twice
because of brexit and one because of
covered we are expecting though in 2021
to have a really good indication about
our funding levels for the next four
years
and we genuinely expect them to be
a poor settlement for local government
as i put within the
um the forecast reserve statement
we will be in a deficit budget position
of several million pounds a year
throughout 2.8 million pounds
in 23 24 unless we do something to
address those costs and
yeah it's inevitable that if we didn't
do this
the impact upon public services would be
significantly higher if we weren't in
isolation to try and deliver that level
of savings without
trying to deliver them in partnership
with another another local authority
owner
i think tony jake would have that sorry
i'm just wondering if we should put
forward i mean i've got four questions
on council tax if we should put all of
those out there can't suggest and then
you can
deal with it all is that okay just to
save you time um
because it is that i think that might
give you more review of what that
means concerns are so shout out to you
thank you does that answer your question
councillor
so uh um i guess the answer is that um
it doesn't benefit
the pockets of residents of chapel and
even then
i i don't think i said that i think
we the proposals seek to preserve as
many council functions as possible
and if you weren't working to fight by
district council then the assumption
already within the immediate term
financial plan was to increase council
tax by the maximum permissible amount
and and that that is what's being
proposed um at least the next couple
years
ultimately though and i think i've made
a point twice now this isn't a decision
for this council to make
if if being merged it would be the first
decision for the new
council to make it wouldn't and and that
would be what they would need to do at
that particular time
in order to balance their budget at that
point
thank you very much um mr buckland
that's does that help you out
counselor fitter yeah um i'm gonna move
on to a question from councillor crump
he's messaged that some of my residents
have asked a question about the super
district
would there be a referendum similar to
the one that warrick district council
proposed about a five pounds per month
green climate charge
the residents have advised councillor
crump that the merger wasn't mentioned
in the 2019 manifestos
so councillors don't have a mandate for
this so will there be a referendum on
any council
tax increases
so opinion are you are you gonna ask
several questions and then let's just
yeah okay then then i'm just pausing so
that the question could land
then we're going to move on to
councillor junaid then councillor
frankly
and then councillor wally hoggins
councillor tunis yes i i wanted to
highlight a slightly wider issue i mean
for example when you
look at the comparison in the council
tax uh
it has highlighted the reduction in
services in the district stratfor
district
uh compared to warwick district over
over some years but
my question is actually more about the
differences in parishes and parish
precepts
um the dip stratford had a policy for
many years to keep the council tax down
by pushing some services
to the parishes and the parish precepts
as a result
uh rose now stratford has about 115
parishes
warwick district council has 20
stratford has a range of parish precepts
between
152 pounds 32 at farnborough to nil
in some cases and most of that is
because
green spaces and play areas for example
are mostly maintained by the
parishioners except in stratfor town
where they are maintained by the
district
so for example we end up with al ulster
having a parish precept of 134 pounds
and stratford having a parish precept of
39
40 pounds mainly because of the
difference in the maintenance of
of green spaces play areas
warwick district council has a maximum
range of its parish precepts between
about 30 pounds
over all its parish precepts because or
it keeps
keeps control of all the players so this
is going to be something that
is has not been discussed so far but
there is going to be
i mean some of the parish precepts are
larger than the district council precept
and and that is going to have quite a
dif make a difference on
residents um pockets um so i
i really do think that that needs to be
um discussed and clarified exactly um
what what this services are and why
some of that there is such a wide range
uh because if you had to add
some of the maximum on 152 onto
the stratfor district council precept
you're putting that 27 pound 74
into stark uh relief very big difference
thank you councillor junior can i ask
people please to keep their questions
succinct
um and can we now move on to counselor
uh fragility please
thank you chair my council tax bill is
compiled from
uh for more than one council
obviously because i have to pay district
county and uh town and the police
commissioner
um i i don't expect this
decision to be made solely on uh council
tax
and i suppose my i'm making an
observation really in that
if i did look at it from council tax i'd
want to know
what i was going to get not me
personally but
you know the communi community we're
going to get
and if i've got one council attack from
the south warwickshire council and um
plus the county council
um at one level or if the county if the
county council decided to go
unitary would i then find i'm paying
more to the county council as a unitary
uh as opposed to what i would be paying
to
the the south right ship council on to
county council
thank you thank you councillor that's a
very interesting question um and then
finally coming on to councillor wally
hoggins
yes thank you uh chair um how will this
merger then if we're going to have if
our residents are going to have to
endure
um an increase in crump i
will sorry liz i think you're not on
mute
i pick a pun how will this merger
then and the increase in council tax
that our residents will have to endure
benefit our residents what noticeable
difference will our residents
see thank you councilory hawkins so
um council jefferson and um mr buckland
if there's any response to the council
tax element of the questions please
uh if i could respond first chair
and then i'm sure david will come in in
response
uh joining reverse order in response to
counselor wally hoggins question
uh given what's already in the budget
for cost savings
from the merger if the budget does not
go ahead
then it is inevitable that residents
will see services cut
uh that is absolutely clear from the
financial position of the council
uh picking up uh councillor fragilis
question
uh council jason can i just come in
there just very quickly
i think that the um driving point of
counseling hobby's question was what
benefits will they see are you saying
the benefits will be that services won't
be cut
correct okay thank you
fine picking up a councillor frankly's
question
uh given the uh information that uh mr
brooklyn put up on his slides
i would say that the probability is
that if there were a single county
unitary
the council tax for stratford residents
would be higher
than under emerged warwick and stratford
scenario but again that will probably
need working through and it is rather
unfortunate that those
um working through were
not in the watershed county council's
submission
uh picking up some of the other points
when it comes to the parishes and
precepts
and what the parishes do i think that
will be a decision for the new council
because obviously if you're merging two
organizations together
and they operate differently
then there will need to be some
harmonization
and the reality actually is the new
council will have to decide
on the level of harmonization and how to
move from where we are now
to where we where the new council
decides it wants to be
um i think i've covered most of the
issues um
jim would you consider
the first point that was raised by
cancer crop in relation to the
referendum
the the proposals the report that was
prepared by um deloitte absolutely talks
about public consultation
and it talks about also consultation
with stakeholders and and
that via businesses and other sectors of
public safety across the
the wider volunteer it doesn't propose a
referendum
in relation to this issue um in relation
to the
town and parish councils yes stratford
has got a wide variation of
parish um i think 113 at last count of
which not all of them actually uh
preset some of them only have paul
parish meetings
there is a difference between the
responsibilities at stratford and
that with why well the one difference
that we have identified is that
the the stratfor district publishes
generally the burial authority whereas
that
case in monk is that it is the district
council so that is an issue
that would need to be considered
thoroughly as part of any
coming together um as far as
what struck this place yes traffic
district council does pay
spend money on public open spaces in
stratford district uh search traffic
town
of course we've had the debate in the
past around the car parking machines
which are generated within stratford
that go a long way
towards meeting those costs i think also
what district council does have some of
their own parks
within their district that they maintain
and don't the local town
can punish precepts don't precept for
those i don't i think there are some
similarities between the two there
if we had a unitary council in response
to council
council franchise question there would
be a harmonized level of tax
from that new warranty authority it
would be the same level of tax
across the police you wouldn't then get
a separate district council element
alongside
the launch accounting element so but as
a refer back to the slide
earlier the the range in district
council
council tax bandies because it's quite
significant across the place
stratford's is proposed 149 pounds
why not meetings is at 240
if you did a simple average of the two
that would be somewhere about 190 pounds
across
the piece would be the district element
that would be added to
the county council element now we don't
know of course that would be a
decision for any future like
unity authority departure unitary
authority to make so i thought we can't
be sure
how they would address that unit that
that harmonization issue but it would
it would exist for them but a bigger
issue than it does exist between
stratford and mike
i think tony's mentioned that responding
to the political council wally hogan's
in relation to the benefits
and i hope the slide demonstrated what
the benefits are
from the proposed work with boyd to our
median term financial plan
without those level of savings there
would have to be
further reductions in service proposed
that would impact the construct on live
industry council residents
it does seem and i think james made the
point last night that the public
do not seem too adverse to savings in
back office services back at the actual
administration of the local authority
but what they would be adverse to is
reductions of value services
do i say things like leisure public
conveniences those kind of things which
have remained untouched as part of the
budget proposals going forward on the
22nd february
thank you very much mr buckland i'm
afraid you froze just when you responded
to council trump's question about the
referendum on my
feed i'm sure everyone else was fine but
what was the response about a public
referendum around the increasing council
tax
so there isn't a proposed referendum
included within the the clients report
what was being spoken about was full
public consultation we are blessed that
we have simon perfield
a consultation manager that's undertaken
several consultations on behalf of the
local authority
and we would expect that to be the kind
of
way that we would engage with the public
through public consultation
just out of interest with that with the
experience they've had in public
consultation what has been the
percentage of uptake from the residents
in consultation
enough to make it statistically
significant i can't give you the exact
figures but simon is a member of the uh
national research association and people
to ensure that any evidence coming
forward would
comply with that to make sure that you
can place reliance upon the results
thank you so just just for somebody
who's not a statistician such as myself
as you all know would that be above 50
of our residents do you think or is it
less than that it would be significantly
lower than 50
but it i i could be i could ask simon
for what would be the pool
if that would be helpful to make sure
that the results are representative of
the
the wider geography of the district if
you to get a sample size
yeah i think that would be really
helpful and just so if it's not done by
a referendum how is it being done
public consultation is that because
referendum is the most public view for
consultation we haven't determined that
as yet so i think
i think it would be the the absolutely
the lux report and the covering reports
talks about
public consultation it will be done to a
format that
our council and white would be happy
with so there's time to inform that
so we haven't made those decisions yet
exactly the exact form the exact size
how we would do it but but there was a
commitment there to have
full consultation undertaken that's good
to know because obviously
um the secretary of state for housing
communities and local government says
that locally led changes to the
structure of local government
whether in the form of unitarization or
district mergers can with
local support the inappropriate means of
ensuring more suitable local government
local service delivery so obviously that
public consultation
is is a vital thing to start flagging up
to people early on in the process
um so that's a relief here that it's
built in um i think we have a follow-up
from councillor wally hoggins
yes to go back to the council tax and so
forth can you
hear this mentioned a lot um could you
please tell me
specifically which services would be cut
if these council tax rises didn't go
ahead
or this murder specifically i want to
know please
and our residents will want to know
which services
will be cut thank you
i think in all honesty counselor wally
hoggins
we can't give you details on that but if
you were to look at the medium term
financial plan
you will see from 22 23 onwards
there are savings identified that would
take out
things like ubus at the reality actually
is we would have to follow that
up and take out even more services to
balance the budget
i am pretty sure we could put something
together but
in all honesty that will be quite an
artificial
measure suffice to say we would need to
save about one and a quarter million
pounds
additional a year given we only spend
about 15 million
i am pretty sure you can work out that
would mean some fairly substantial cuts
in services
so you know not really no it doesn't
thank you
okay um i think that covers everything
for council mr buckland did you have
anything else you wish to add to that
no i i look because the savings from
work have been built into the budget we
haven't had to
consider any further reductions in in
service
but when the work of the council
recovery advisory group was being
considering that the budget proposal was
coming forward
it would be the discretionary functions
that the council undertakes
that would be i'm sure considered first
by any kind of future reductions in the
expenditure and we can't predict what
counts
because that would have to be a decision
for a future council to make if we were
to deliver that level of savings
but the discretionary functions are
those that include things like leisure
public conveniences street cleaning
those are the kind of discretionary
functions that we undertake as a local
authority
so if we were we're here to do a duty
we're here to pick the bins up we're
here to
provide environmental health planning
services those kind of functions
they would be more protected than the
discretionary functions which then i
said
cctv is a function that we provide that
our public
really supports but it is a
discretionary function that everyone
um this isn't child waiting you've asked
a question about what would have to be
considered
we don't know but that all of those kind
of discretionary concerns would have to
be considered
so what i'm picking up actually is that
residents will need to know
what type of services might be at risk
when they're considering whether this
is because it's just about messaging
isn't it to our residents and obviously
we know you've got a very thorough
report from deloitte's and you've had a
lot of consultation between yourselves
about this
but when this is actually a format that
will have to be sold to residents if you
want them to engage
with a consultation then um
i would suggest because you you will
know what a discretionary service is but
a lot of people would need that
clarified and i think that might be the
point that
council warning hawkins was driving out
with coming back asking specifically
which ones
i think we had a general idea as you've
just done there mr buckland about well
street cleaning leisure
that will that would advise also
highlighting what the district council
does is still a misconception about what
we do compared with what
rochester county council doing it's
nationwide you see the the um
infograms don't you on social media
explaining what different councils do
i'll come to you in just a moment
councillor
mills is it regarding um council tax
council mills
probably not but it's about social
services so that's
on another heading yeah that's i think
we're coming onto that one later aren't
we um
can i just can i quickly get back to the
idea about public consultation i think
this will also pull in i think it was
councillor frankly he had a question
about the timeline
um so why i understand with regards to
the whole local government picture
around reduction in funding from central
government
um but why is the cabinet making these
proposals an agreement expenditure of
three hundred thousand pounds over three
years without first establishing
this public support for this particular
plan
and what's our plan b what other options
have been considered
you're not merging or merging with
another authority
and if they have been considered where
is the analysis of these options i'm not
seeing a lot of
option analysis detail brought forward
so can you just give us the background
on what's been happening that's led you
to thinking this
is the best deal for our wonderful
district and our residents
i think if i could pick that up chair i
think it's when you look at the fit
between uh stratfor district
and warwick district the fit and the
synergies
are really considerable uh
we haven't considered any other options
in detail
because and if you look at the delights
report
it actually did reinforce
just how close the fit is
um and i think the reality actually is
as well um councils are meant to provide
community leadership
and in reality as the world changes i
think what we are doing at the moment
is providing that community leadership
i mean the difference between 2019 and
now
is really quite stark and we have
responded to
a massive change in circumstances
i think that's what residents elect us
to do
thank you council jefferson um so just
quickly picking up
and i completely agree with you that we
are um a nimble and flexible
organization responding to our place
within the community absolutely
so just given the amount of work and
you've put a considerable amount of work
into this and i'm
not sure 100 of what the costings thus
far have been with deloitte's
um what is the response from from
whitehall about this what is robert
generick and paul rousell saying in
response to these
to this application are you getting
positive feedback they may be responsive
or is it that actually
they're concentrating on covid
encouraging the rest of the country and
local government to do that for now
and this is something that could be
postponed i mean what's your view about
the response you're going to get from
the powers that be that then decide if
this can even be considered with all the
work you've put in thus far
my picture of the response from
the department is that the paper on
local government reform will be issued
after the county council elections in
may
so the reality actually is there may be
a pause but it will not be a long
prolonged pause we have kept the
department
in the loop in terms of everything we
are doing
we've had no negative feedback as yet
they are willing to consider submissions
and one of the issues is and it's one of
the issues why we are doing the work now
is that often when they ask for
submissions the time scales
they put on the submissions are so tight
that if we have not done preparatory
work we would not be able to meet the
deadlines
no absolutely you can be pushed into
corner with timelines so you say
that um the whitehall is positive what
specific positive feedback have you had
what specific dialogue and conversations
have been had
um you know what is the positive
feedback and any
actual sign of specific government
support for our
proposal not about the general district
mergers but specifically
sdc wdc because we are focusing on that
today rather than the national picture
specifically we have had letters from
the department
uh both andrew day and i have written to
the department we've had very specific
responses on our proposals uh
i would have to go back and read the
letters
but i'd be quite happy to share the
correspondence with you chair
that would be so helpful thank you so
much um and just as
a general idea what did the letter say
just to reassure people that we are on
the right lines because i'm just aware
that you've put so much work into this
whilst also dealing with the pandemic
council jefferson that the reality
actually is
that the department will be happy to
receive a submission from us
brilliant that's good to know thank you
councillor jefferson so we know we're on
the right tracks with westminster on
that one a white hall cat
mr buckland thank you i just wanted to
respond and it was actually
quoted within the the deloitte's report
an extract from
a memo that was sent to conservative
councillors by prophet general back in
october
which was actively asking effectively
local authorities to consider such
mergers so i think from that perspective
that the current secretary of state has
indicated that there is support
for such a line of activity i haven't
contacted paul rousseau
directly about this potential merger
some of it is
chicken and egg when do you approach do
you approach when you've i think i go
back to what i said earlier what is
being asked for council at the moment is
a consideration of this vision is this
the kind of sense of direction
one might say that it's inappropriate to
ask a question until you've tested the
opinion of members i i just don't know
when you ask that question formally to
say
we're serious now about this and that we
will be coming forward at some point
with
a formal proposal which will be subject
again as i said earlier to further
consideration by council so
at this point it's just that that
indication that that
kind of direction of travel if you like
that stratfor it would be considered
that that way forward thank you mr
buckland could you just
just clarify for me how much has it cost
us thus far with the reports in the
investigation
okay so the report has been jointly
commissioned the the delights report it
costs 45 000 between the two authorities
so our contribution to that is 22.5
000. thank you so much it's just i think
when we're so
financially strapped um people will
wonder what research has been done
before we paid out but i understand
you're saying it's a very difficult
um navigation of an unknown at the
moment almost
and i would respond to that that yes it
is a lot of money 22.5 000 is a lot of
money but this is a
significant decision that the council is
being asked to consider
and you know it it's one which is
considering the abolitionist strategic
council that you
you don't get much bigger than that so
from that perspective to have some
independent
research to help the local authority i
think is entirely appropriate
and i think as well council jefferson
with the timelines you never know what
they're going to ask you
to do from whitehall with regards to
that i don't know if this is a good time
to bring in
councillor fragile regarding his
timetabling question
um i'm not quite sure how this fits in
at this point in the conversation
shall i come back to your counselor for
actually if you may yes that's okay
right let's move on to the next question
okay i think we also had a question
regarding the partnership between
warwickshire
right district council and stratfor
district council from both
councillor wally hoggins and counselor
junard counselor wally hoggins
thank you chair um why does warwick want
to merge with sdc
because we are clearly the poorer
cousins here
what is it what's in it for them thank
you
i i think if i can pick that up uh
but the reality is we both consider that
we are far
stronger together the reality is that
both our budgets are under pressure and
if we actually look to the future we
think that
combining we are much stronger we can
provide
better services and not only that and
it's something that's often
uh overlooked we have much more
influence in terms of working with some
of the
really important bodies that are around
like the coventry and warwickshire local
enterprise partnership
unlike the combined authority uh the
point that was made
last night which is really significant
in the west midlands our combined uh
districts would have the second biggest
gva
after birmingham it is very very
significant
so we we see we are much stronger
together
we've had a number of joint meetings of
cabinets
and there is absolutely no doubt about
it
we all at cabinet level understand
they the significance of getting
together
uh edward fitter has asked what gva
gva is gross value added uh
in reality it's a proxy measure for
economic output
thank you very much councillor jefferson
um can i just quickly come on
just pick up a point about the the joint
working and the synergy between
warwick and stratford if i may so in the
deloitte report there
um they were proving that there's a
single economic geography across south
warwickshire that relied on data
on commuting that showed that i thought
it was really very interesting 500 5248
residents commute from warwick district
area to stratford
and that 581 residents commute from
stratfor district to warwick district do
we know
where these figures come from chairman
can i respond to that yeah
that was the 2011 census that we we
don't have any other
travel to work information of course
29th of march this year we've got the
21 cent please take part in the census
when that when
the the forms come through but yeah that
that is up to date is the information we
have
indeed yeah and my question coming back
to you is are you happy that we're
basing
there are um investigations on
ten-year-old data even given the fact
that we've got this census coming up
and given the way that work patterns
have transformed in the past 12 months
do we not need a better understanding of
the magic
economic geography before taking a
decision like this so i think it's
coming back to the timeline again
i think what you've got to remember is
that at the moment we're dealing with
principles and vision uh and we are
using the best data we've got available
and one would actually hope that
despite what we've been through over the
last almost a year now
that some form of normality would
creep back into the system over the next
couple of years
uh all i would say is that the data we
are basing it on
seems to me to be uh really quite
powerful
the 2011 census yeah
best data we've got unfortunately okay
so
i'd argue it's the best you've got but
i'd say it's ten years out of date
um but thank you thank you councillor
jefferson i just know we've got quite a
few questions coming in
thick and fast i know that counselor
rolf has a question
and counselor june is sorry cancer
junior um before that and i think
councilman mills your question is quite
similar to cancer junior so councillor
mills
and then council junior then councillor
rolfe and then councilor wally hoggins
i'm on yes thank you thanks madam
chairman yes um
yeah my concerns with um sdc
and uh uh you know as a uni
with uh sorry sdc and roy district
council are the uh
essential services um
we've got uh education social care and
fire service as well um as an authority
will be able to cope with this
and you know because uh that's under the
umbrella of
county council at the moment and because
i
again it looks like there'd be enormous
cost involved
so uh thank you councillor mills we are
talking about a merger between two
districts to create a super district
the county council will still exist and
will still provide those services
so so
so we're not cherry-picking then no we
use their services because we can't yeah
we're going
as a we're joining with warwick district
but then we're not providing the service
we're okay
we are creating a super district council
of mills
a super district is merely two districts
combining together
eight does not replace the two-tier
system
okay thank you
can i just quickly come in um on that
what will happen with the legal services
that you're currently buying from orange
county accounts will that continue
with that format or is that something
we're taking over the super district
uh i think the super district uh there
will be a review
of all the operations of the district
i think it is more than likely that
legal services will come in house
and that's been allocated budget-wise as
well
yes thank you leader um
moving on to councillor juniors yes but
warwick district council does provide
quite a number of additional services
that stratford district council does not
provide
notable for example more much more on
economic development but also housing
and they have a housing company
so and culture and arts they have a have
that provision
i would like to see if we are going to
have an increase
in counter tax then we we should benefit
there should be some harmonization
what have you thought about that
harmonization of services across the two
parts for this super district
in principle yes councillor junior in
detail
no we are still at very early stages
and if you listen to an awful lot of the
questions that have been asked
you'll appreciate there is an awful lot
more work to do
at the moment we are focusing on the
principles and the vision
to take us to the next stage and
the more we talk the more we realize how
much work will need to be done
in bringing together two organizations
and providing harmonized services and
facilities
for the residents of south warwickshire
um i think what people are picking up on
though leader is the
the financial commitment thus far for
this vision with the 300
000 committed um future planning i think
that's possibly what keeps the these
detail questions coming up um
okay i think we also have a question can
i just pick up on that
yeah because if you look at that
commitment compared to the savings that
both councils will actually make
that actually makes their medium-term
financial strategies work
i think that sets the appropriate
context
thank you leader mr button did you have
a comment
yeah i i think i think we were of
members raising concerns about the 300
000 to review
the lessons learned from the taunton
dean and somerset west merger
where it was identified that
under-resourced project management
seriously impacted upon
the delivery of the expected outcomes
from
from the merger um that i think we made
it available as a link to the
cabinet report but i would urge members
to do that and of course
what would be negligent if we didn't
learn lessons from other local
authorities that have been down the same
path
so the level of uh contribution is 300
000 pounds from each local authority
you write 600 000 pounds combined to
deliver
recurring savings as to 4.6 million so
that's a one-off 600 000 against 4.6
million per year
this is the assumption and then yeah i i
i fully commend to council
properly resourcing project management
because
if if we're not managed in this process
and things can go wrong we've
had chris elliott and myself who's the
chief executive at warwick have
an excellent conversation with steve
baker who's the chief executive of east
suffolk council
they had something like 300 work streams
that they managed
through the merger of their two local
authorities and absolutely brought in
support to make that happen and and
derive the best benefits
for communities and businesses after
that so yeah i would personally defend
the 300 000 as being a modest sum
given the potential savings which uh
could be derived from the spell of
its merger thank you mr burkland you've
actually answered my next question which
which was going to be that the summerset
western
taunton audit report on their merger
stated that the expected benefits were
actually outweighed by them going over
budget so that is the 300 000 from us is
a buffer yes
trying to prevent that happening okay
well that clarifies that point for me
thank you very much
and so by incorporating more budget for
change management you are ensuring that
we don't come according to the same
same problem as they did thank you um
okay so i think we then go on to
councillor
wally hoggins then councillor curtis
thank you um i just want to go back
please to uh why the
um councillor mills raised with you um
council jefferson that um
in your opening statement there was some
discussion about
the fact the the overview and um
if you like the single unitary the
proposal from warwickshire
so actually there would be an
expectation that moving down the line
that we will have to take responsibility
for these services and that was alluded
to
otherwise we are doing this or proposing
this amalgamation
and then we will still be sucked into a
a massive unitary so
i think i do think that um i do think i
need some further clarification on that
it's all very well saying that no this
is just the merger of two districts
no we we fully know that this district
is being this this murder of the two
districts is being done to
obviate the sucking into um a single
unitary and the single and the unitary
authority
would take responsibility for social
care education
etc so there will be an expectation that
this super south district
will eventually have to take
responsibility for these areas of which
neither warwick nor stratford has any
um experience in in
in doing that um so that was just a pull
up about that i would like a response to
but also the deloitte report highlights
the questions
hoggins what is your specific question
regarding the services
the question is are we going to be
then going through this and then
potentially becoming a single
warwickshire unitary or will we be
making a bid to take over the services
uh as and when um services are run by
warwickshire county council
in the fullness of time thank you thank
you for cancelling hawkins i think you
had another question after that and then
it's counselor role for counselor curtis
i do have another question and the
question is um that um
what consideration have been given to
the fact that in the deloitte's report
it highlights that any marginal failure
to realize the savings could result in
in
in negligible or no savings being
actually realized and therefore making
the
combining with warwick almost null and
void
so what consideration has been given to
that
part of the deloitte report please can i
pick that up please chair
i think mr brookland uh covered that
point in his answer to the previous
question
the reason why we put 300 000 pounds in
the budget
is to actually make sure there is proper
project management
and the work is done and i have to say
that when i was in the private sector i
went through three merges
the absolute significance of making sure
one's got
adequate project management and adequate
management of the process is
absolutely key i've no doubts about it
that the way we are thinking about it at
the moment
we will not fall into the same trap a
lot of other councils have
and if i just make the point that
this paper going to council on monday
is about joint districts
it is not about unitaries
unitaries may be a decision further down
the track
and that is a decision that will come
back to cabinet and council
but at the moment it's about a joint
district uh mr buckland
yeah chairman also i'm responsible
councilwoman
is absolutely right this isn't without
risk and and the paper is
is honest and it provides 15 specific
risks which we've identified
that we need to manage and mitigate if
we're going to go forward with this
vision
there's some proposed mitigation within
the report from deloitte says how to
overcome some of the concerns
that you've raised but it would have to
be a very well managed process so
i do accept that and and and reverting
back again to the sunset western taunton
there's some learning points there about
how not to do things there was some some
learning points that we could benefit
from but also in discussion with some
as east southwark and west suffolk
there's also some very positive learning
points that could help deliver
significant savings for the the
authorities moving forward
and we we have had the offer from east
surface
east suffolk that their leader uh
councillor steve gallant would talk to
our council
about some of their learning points if
we wanted to benefit from that in the
future
very valuable yeah i think the idea that
you're in consultation with
people who've gone through a similar um
project would be incredibly valuable
um and also to be made public part of
that to
our residents just to explain what's
ahead with these sort of visions i think
the sign posting for this the navigation
for residents is key
that they are kept up to date with what
this actually involves
um now councillor rolfe has waited
incredibly patiently i do apologize for
missing you out councillor rolfe you're
next
um thank you chair it is unfortunate
because the previous um
speaker sort of almost asked the
question that i was going to ask
and i'm going to ask anyway
so um this is to uh
tony jefferson um i mean part of the
reason
this is being proposed is to protect the
two districts
and to become a super district
but there is absolutely no
reason that a single unitary
will suck us in and take us in as a
single unitary
somebody will make that decision and you
know
what are the implications of that going
through
all this cost for a super district
to find out that two years along the
line we're sucked into a single unitary
and and it could happen and possibly
will happen
thank you councillor i think that
actually that that is summarizing the
concerns that
a lot of us have raised in our
questioning yes so um with councillor
jefferson and then perhaps over council
buttons
i'm so sorry but i keep i keep is it an
emotion or a promotion i'm not sure
i call you counsellor
okay i'm leaving that one open right
counselor i just pick up on that point
um
there is a very clear message coming
from the center
that uh the proposals actually
for any local government reorganization
have to have the support of local people
and local authorities and
the reality actually is that at the
moment
uh all the districts and boroughs are
united
in not wanting a single warwickshire
unitary now
that's one of the reasons why we are
working
on a joint district and
interesting enough in parallel with this
meeting
i could have been at a meeting of all
the district and borough leaders because
we are continually talking about this
uh my sense at the moment is
that a single warwickshire unitary is by
no means a foregone conclusion
uh we would not be doing this if we
thought it was a foregone conclusion but
it certainly isn't
there is a long way to go on this and
um my view and i think the view of
all well no i know the view of all the
leaders
of the districts and borders is that a
two unitary solution for warwickshire
would from our perspective be a lot
better
so i do not accept that a single
warranty unity is a foregone conclusion
can i quickly come in and just ask a
question in in response to that council
jefferson
with your um liaison with whitehall what
what is do you know what their vision
for warwickshire is as we're talking
about the potential
unitarization what is whitehall's vision
for warwickshire
are we aware of that as we're going
through these various plans and jumping
through various hoops and having these
costs
do we know what their vision for for
warwickshire actually is
the honest answer to that is no and i
think
in all honesty they are very much
open to alternatives
and certainly when we've also involved
the mps in an awful lot of this debate
and at the moment the consensus amongst
the mps
is a two unitary solution would be
preferred
um you've actually just picked up one
question i wanted to ask the beginning
where were the
supportive statements from the mps with
regards to
our papers around this subject i mean
where have we got it actually in written
confirmation that they are supportive of
this idea
rather than the unitarization the single
unitarization
uh all i can say is this was mainly
discussed in face-to-face
well actually uh virtual meetings
yeah face-to-face was a long time ago
now it is yes
um that both nadeem zawari and
um matt in warrick lamington
and um jeremy southern they are all
we have had discussions where the
leaders of all the districts and borders
and the mps have been there
and they understand and the picture i
get from
all the mps and from all the leaders
when they talk to their mps
is that there is support for two unitary
solution
in preference to a single unitary thank
you okay i can see mr buckland wants to
come in
thank you councillor jefferson
so no no it counts accounts i'm coming
back to you with a follow-up don't worry
i can see you gesticulating at me there
but
i'm coming in because i saw him sighing
and that's his non-verbal that he's
ready to add something
mr buckland yeah well i've been very
brief so and and the leader said hello
i think the position a formal position
from the mps would be required before
any formal submission is made
at a later point for formal
consideration about whether we want to
become a unitary authority or not this
is at the moment
two local party areas two sovereign
areas set in a vision that they would
then go out and consult with
the residents public other stakeholders
which would include mp so i think there
will be plenty of time for that kind of
um discussion later on i personally see
this as two district councils who have
got both financial problems i think
that the reference was made earlier
about white being a much
favorable financial position to us
they've got four and a half million
pounds a year savings that they need to
deliver
themselves and this is a big part of
their moving together and we're taking
the initiative to ensure that we
remain financially sustainable into the
longer term as
district councils we're not we're not
this isn't in response to council of
mills and
others this is purely at this stage just
think of it as a parish
community governance review two parishes
come together that's what this is
effectively two districts coming
together if we were overtaken by events
and that we become a wider or extra
unity and another point
i suppose the only issue is that you'll
be then merging
five local authorities not six and
you'll have some learning points from
what happened at stratford around
bringing together some of those
districts and functions that would have
to be subsumed into a wider
voluntary council so i don't i don't i
see that there will be benefits in the
short term
outweigh the cost of implementation and
it could also
lead some learning points for the future
should that be the decision of
government ultimately in relation to
whilst your local government
thank you so much mr buckland um
counselor rolfe i know you have a
follow-up
thank you um i can assure you my vision
is not a single unitary
at all never was never will be um
however if it
came to there are many many many people
in workshop that would like a single
unitary
and it could if it came to a referendum
or to a vote
um it could be that um
that we'd lose the option of the the
south and the north i mean i've always
wanted um a south north um
as a party we put it forward to the
county council
um 11 years ago we put the proposition
um and it was just pushed under the
carpet so
i'm very much in favor of the north and
south unitary and not
a single unitary thank you thank you
councillor rolf
i i am pleased to have your support
thank you canceroff uh lovely moving on
then not sure i said i supported what
you said tony
i support a north south unitary
everyone clear okay so um
just just just a quick going back a
little bit i want to check
with both mr buckland and um councillor
jefferson
um and we've talked about the mps being
in agreement
i know we're just talking about a
possibility of a merger here but does it
concern you that we seem to be a little
bit out of the loop with what
whitehall and westminster are thinking
about a vision for warwickshire
is that of any concern to you both
frankly at this point in time chair no
because uh in doing the work that we're
doing
and assuming the decisions go through
both
councils next week then we will actually
uh resume communicating with the
department
but i think it's essential to get
through this stage and say look
now it's real then i think that will be
the time to start communicating in much
more detail
with the department i mean until
unless if these go through then we're in
a position
to really start a proper dialogue with
them
and and chairman in fact for me also i
think it would help
mike hall influence the debate in
relation to the future structure or
local government within manchester
at the moment the only authority that's
made a formal submission to central
government without any consultation of
public
any stakeholders is the county council
they did so in a very healthy fashion
uh last year and that's the only
proposition the government have got on
the table at present and i think
we can help inform the debate by making
this decision and then starting the
conversation about whether it's
a proposition or not that government are
willing to consider so i think
if we're serious about you know trying
to set our own destiny rather than have
it imposed upon us
then i personally think it is at least
having that confidence why did i love
them conversation
so you're saying it's on a different
timeline basis so the county council
submitted theirs but they had a
lawyer's report as well didn't they were
similar the head of christopher house
cooper's report yeah
yeah and they would have had the similar
meetings that we're having with that
yeah
but can i make the distinction please
counselor donald o'donnell they've made
a formal submission for consideration
for local government review
at washington county council they did so
before
any consultation with the mention has
been mated over about a referendum
there is no consultation whatsoever with
the public they've done retrospective
consultation with parishes i'm
aware of that and and and i understand
they're doing some public consultation
now
but before they made their submission
they made no
in endeavors to consult in indeed with
the district council
as well within the strategic change
document they considered
they've listed the stakeholders and
district empowered councils were
completely emitted from that document
okay so you're reassuring us that before
you make your submission
to whitehall there will be public
consultation
it's not my submission it would be
council submission yes
absolutely it would be following full
cut so
what's being considered next monday it's
just this is something that council is
interested in is this is this
a direction of travel we've done a lot
of work including full
consultation before then any formal
submission is made back to central
government as to whether
it's a view that council supports or not
at that point so
i i believe that that that's a proper
way of doing it i understand that it was
time to go that's why
a different approach was taken by the
county earlier that well last year
thank you for myself um
with regards i know talk about the 300
000 being changed and the buffer
does that include cost for public
consultation it would include
public consultations yes okay thank you
council jefferson
yes can i just reinforce exactly what mr
brookland has said
we are taking time and we intend
doing this very thoroughly before we're
in a position to make
a formal submission the reality is as i
said we've already
indicated to the department that we will
be preparing this submission
uh my view would be assuming that
these papers go through both our cabin
both our councils next week then we
would actually inform the department of
progress
and say we are well on the way and these
are the next steps
so we are trying to do a very thorough
job
in terms of how we prepare and how we
consult
and you are absolutely right chair it is
really important there is an
uh significant amount of public
consultation
to make sure there is support from the
public
uh for this but i come back to the point
that in reality
you know it's not a well if we don't do
this stratfor stays as it is
it won't councillor jefferson
um and thank you for clarifying the fact
you're putting as forward as thorough a
case as you can
when you do submit thank you um we've
got some questions uh from both council
of fisher and councillor junaid
regarding the joint working um
but before we go on to that quickly
check if when you go to this public
consultation i'm sorry to keep banging
on about it but i do believe it's very
important
if when you go to this public
consultation if you don't get support
will you simply scrap this um super
district merger idea what what it will
be the plan
b if this has to be scrapped because the
public simply won't buy into it
i think we will have to stand back and
reconsider
council o'donnell
okay so there isn't a plan b if it's at
the moment no
the plan b in reality is if the public
won't buy into this
then what they've actually bought into
by default
is a single warranty unitary
okay and i suppose with this submission
this will um if it goes to submission
this will open up the whole unitary
discussion again anyway won't it with
whitehall yes
okay thank you councillor jefferson
thank you so we're going to go on to
councillors
um fitter and then councillor junaid and
then councillor crump
thank you chair so just wearing my
advice chair of the council hat
for this question um i know i understand
if this hasn't been considered yet and
probably isn't a priority
but civic mayors or chairmen are really
important for community engagement
between
the community and the council has there
been any discussions on
on the future of this
what well
sorry david go on yeah no it's a short
quest
uh response of course until the new
authority is formed
and at that point there would be a new
council chairman for that wider
geography
so so yeah the existing council chairman
for stratford
and while it could be retained until the
point of merger should that be where we
end up
and then yes there would be a chairman
across the wider south launch with that
queen
does that answer your question counselor
about your future post yes
okay moving on to council tuna please
yeah we we've talked a lot about finance
but um
they there is the issue of differing
cultures
warwick district council and stratfor
district council very very different
uh in in the way um they run
and there is there is the potential for
that to become a hurdle so i would hope
that the
project management would look um
would look at the integration of the
cultures
um could this be a problem is this
something you already discussed up for
this
at this stage
the difference in age demographic
between the two districts
yeah just picking up the cultures of the
two councils
yes we are very very well aware of it
counselor junior
uh we've had a a number of discussions
about
it uh we understand it will be
a major issue as it is in all mergers
the one thing that is very clear and
it's something we are now very focused
on
we are going to create a new
organization
for a new council so the reality
actually is
it's what is the culture that new
organization actually going to be
but we are very well aware of
the issues of culture and having been
through mergers myself
believe me culture is the biggest single
issue and the biggest single stumbling
block
but it can be overcome and it will have
to be overcome if you're going to get
together
mind you if you think of the issues of
merging
two organizations imagine the issues
emerging
five sorry six
and the age profile yes the age profiles
are different but i mean there is then
an advantage in actually
uh combining and that we get a much more
balanced age profile in the new council
thank you councillor jefferson does that
answer your question counselor junit oh
sorry mr buckland yeah sorry chairman if
you don't mind
the culture issue is picked up as one of
the risks already within the delight
reports and
certainly would be an issue that we
would need to work on i i just wanted to
give a little bit of reassurance that
chris elliott myself have already
started engagement with
the joint branches of unison and and if
i could just read a
small extract from a statement that
they're produced back to us so this is
from the staff side
of the organization um and it says
stratfor district council branch and
warwick district council unison branches
are committed to working with both
employers in the move towards
collaboration in the future
both branches realize the challenges
that are facing local government due to
the national position of unitary
authorities
and recognize that we will need to work
together to safeguard our services
so we we have already had a very
positive message coming forward from
unison we have a suite of organizational
change documents which are going to be
considered by the
um opium scrutiny committee and that is
going to this is
the employment appointments committee
sorry on the 16th of march
which will help with that further
integration as we work more closely
together so
i just wanted to make that point that
staff
generally are supportive of the
proposals coming forward here
thank you mr buckland and can i just
quickly go back to council jr's point
about the cultures and the reassurance
thank you
council jefferson you've offered about
how the merger could work positively
i'm still not clear and i know it so we
can keep services going what
tangible improvements our residents will
have in their everyday lives from this
joint from the super district what's
going to be the everyday life experience
improvement that they will see from as a
result of all this hard work you've been
putting in
okay i think but i mean i don't know if
you want me to start later then
come here david
to be fair that they were the ten
benefits that that james ran through
last night
in trying to bring the two or three at
least selling some of the
the non-financial benefits of bringing
the two organizations together this
larger local voice
in the conversations we were having with
the chief executive suffolk they were
having far more say
in relation to transportation
initiatives in their locality
than they ever had before when there
were two relatively small districts
the lep and the combined authority take
that organization far more seriously
because it is a bigger economic voice
than it was previously
so i think from the future
infrastructure requirements if nothing
else for
for the wider south launcher that would
be a massive positive
um and i think a lot of it though does
come back to
together where they we're going to be
able to provide far more than we can
in isolation the kind of impact on staff
will be
lesser if we're together we we're
already talking
the report talks about joint
accommodation for
uh potentially new office headquarters
would need to be
one one office rather than two in a much
more small
office than we currently have so the
benefits are
identified within the report i take the
point about
we would need to identify that so what
if this didn't happen
what would there be for them be the
implications upon the budgets at that
stratfor
and we have george who's on the call
he's listened very patiently i don't
know
if he wanted to just bring george in
front of me
come on in george
sorry sorry i was muted yeah i think i
think that
from a budget perspective the key
benefits are that we can retain the
services that the council currently uh
provides and i think it's been alluded
to that
the discretionary services that are the
ones that
are particularly under threat if we have
to make service
cuts are the ones that are particularly
valued by residents
and members i think and that is what
we're projecting largely
and that is a a key benefit to both
councils
and the residents of both areas i think
i think if i merge there's one other
advantage which probably people won't
see for a number of years but it could
end up being very significant
and that's the fact that we will have a
joint south warwickshire plan
and that enables us to uh be
much more strategic and i think the
point that david made about
infrastructure
uh there are many parts of the district
that struggle with
infrastructure at the minute joint south
warwickshire plan
and the fact that we've got more
influence and more clout
means that we should be able to do more
on the infrastructure side
together than we could separately now
these benefits are really quite hard to
sell because they're not going to appear
for several years
but they will appear
that's reassuring thank you councillor
jefferson i think it's something it's
definitely worth flagging up when we're
trying to sell it
um to our residents as well uh
we have i know that counselor crump has
a question then counselor fielding
um and then i have a question and then
i'll come to councillor wally hoggins
council crumb thank you council donald
um
apologist for for likeness um at a
consultant hospital appointment and not
overrun and
i couldn't attend um yesterday's
briefing well i wasn't in the mood to
tell you this briefly it was my
father-in-law's funeral
yesterday so having a great week at the
moment um
so hopefully seeing your smiling face
chair is is a has helped to cheer me up
a bit today so thank you for that
um just uh just a very quickie um well
two points
first of all the consultation on again
i'll be asked about that
maybe i'll be more interested to see
what consultation would involve
and whether we would go down the
referendum route which could be
potentially significant cost or will be
different form of
referendum uh consultation because i
know um
having worked at warwick district
council for 30 odd years so i do know
the difference between the culture and
between stc and wdc um
quite from a unique position as well so
um is quite interesting first of all i
know that there was
last year um muted at wdc
a referendum on a green
tax of five pounds a month if i'm right
i might be slightly right but somewhere
in that
figure and they could be interested but
that that would be carried on and
i think that cost was the referendum was
several hundred thousand pounds and
again i might have
been talking out in the hat so apologies
david can't say no
mr buckland i'll get it right then i
nearly told you that by your counsellor
so sorry david um so that would be
interested
and my other one um is picked up about
the hq
um many years warwick district council
was going to move and i was hoping to
coincide my departure from wdc
with the office move and yeah it might
have been financially advantageous for
that to happen
but unfortunately i couldn't wait that
long and had to leave
at the end of 2019 so it's it's
things like that how long will these
projects take you know uh
and i know the location of any potential
hq
would be quite contentious you know oh
it's too close to stratford it's too
close to warwick it's it's so it's
there are quite a few points to consider
uh and and
we've got a lot to to manage and i know
that the
the gigabytes factory again i might be
talking about using the wrong phrase
at um at concrete airport again that's
potentially a major project um because i
think that i think it actually falls in
warwick district i might do
again i might be wrong but yeah oh well
done tony good stuff
you're right i've got one i'm getting
one or two things right you know it's
the scattergun approach
shooting off bullets and you get one
right now and then um but
can you just can you just clarify your
because it's you're giving us incredibly
informative
um informative viewpoints here what are
your specific questions because
i think these are really valued
questions it's about one
about the capacity if we're going to
have some major projects coming up
and potentially major national
infrastructure projects the gigabyte
factory
um will we have the capacity to do that
if we're taking all these things
again it might be actually the two
together will provide the capacity for
it but it's just a question
about that and the question the time and
the consultation
will the 300 000 be enough and and again
where will the hq because if we're going
to be planning
for again this will obviously take time
and there will be logistics around
planning
and purchasing and procuring a new hq
because
it did take longer at warwick district
council and didn't come to fruition
shall we say i'm trying to be as
delicate as possible there
david i think you're i think you're
getting my ideas so yeah that's
sorry if i've rumbled on i just wanted
to get one two points
so thanks jeff thank you council crown
can i just clarify them
with across the gigabytes you're saying
when there's larger national projects
going on within the
area as well and that's an extra work
stream coming in
to both councils will they have the
capacity to cope with that whilst also
looking at the merger is that the
question
looking at the merger looking at
potential new office location
making sure we consult properly there's
going to be a lot of
resources needed um and you know and
again it's it's
i'm not saying we can't do it and then
again the the merger might be out of
free resources to do that so it's just
just raising that question thank you
thank you councillor cramp
uh mr buckland would you like to go
first on that or george and then
councillor jefferson
okay i'll go first we did discuss the
issue your question previously uh
councillor cromp about whether a full
referendum would be
envisaged as part of this proposal what
what would be undertaking is meaningful
consultation
and and i'm going to come back to the
committee with what size sample that
would mean
for the south bronx here so at this
point we're not proposing a full
referendum
in relation to the proposals um
in relation to the foreign district
council yes they did propose a 50 pounds
increase in their council tax
to as a climate change why not as i'm
concerned
that that isn't progressing that of
course that was a casualty of covered
because they couldn't hold the election
that would have been required
because of the um of the referendum that
would have been required for the 50
pounds increase
so as far as i'm concerned that that has
fallen
the work in relation to future hq i'm
not going to tell you
i i i can't begin to speculate where
that would fall i do know though from
personal experience when i worked at
wife highest
and we had beauty and kinderminster two
big towns that both wanted to host
um wife
usually i'm sure some kind of compromise
would be
um devised in relation to that sticky
issue about where future headquarters
would be
can i just quickly come in um about the
capacity as well
it would be a major ask for the two
local parties but the alternative is
that we have to
slash and burn budget so i think i think
we would have to either create capacity
out of 300 000
or even on something like the project on
relation hq
resource that properly in its own right
because there would be a capital receipt
which would be generated from the sale
of
both elizabeth house and riverside house
so to enable us to invest in a new
facility
together can i just quickly come in
because my um internet froze slightly
can you just confirm why we're not doing
a referendum on
the um public consultation aspect of
this
okay um what we're talking about is
submission a proposal which has to have
local
support and that can be derived by way
of a consultation which would be
far less costly than the full referendum
i think council
mentioned the several hundreds of
thousands of pounds of would have cost
in relation to the um the climate change
premium to 56 pounds a year that we're
considering so yes
it's a cosmetic perspective okay thank
you very much mr buckland council
jefferson was there anything you wanted
to add
yes oh david's absolutely right on the
scale of the cost of a referendum at the
cost running to many hundreds of
thousands
just for one district and i think uh
councillor crump has actually made a
good point
uh probably in reverse but
the reality actually is combining
we will have greater scale and greater
resource
yes we have to go through the issue of a
merger
but if you start to look at it jointly
together
we do have the scale and the expertise
to do far more than we do
separately i'm just picking up finally
the point on the hq
uh there is no doubt about it that the
role and nature of hqs will change
really quite significantly i mean the
reality is there will be more people
working from home
uh both organizations will need
even independently would need smaller
hq's
we'll have to do work in terms of what
kind of hq we want
and where it will be and in an ideal
world it probably would not be
in warrick clemington or stratford but
that's a decision for another day
well thank you council jefferson
councillor jefferson plenty of room in
southam
[Laughter]
we need it we need a passport for that
um okay can i please bring
um mr parkerson at this point please our
deputy chief executive
uh thank you um chairman
um thank you just quick few comments at
this point you asked me in the chat
it's been really interesting sort of
listening to what's been said so far
and i think what we're looking for here
at this stage we must do something
there's an early stare about is this
something that as a counselor we want to
pursue
and we're just we're looking for a
student a lot of questions about detail
which are all really interesting
challenges for us that we have to
address but at the moment we invest a
lot of time and energy in this we want
to know
is this something that we're looking for
support going forward that's what we're
asking for
at council this week um
i'll go through the list if you don't
mind um we talked a lot about sort of
referenda i think we must lose sight of
the fact that you are the elected
representatives of the people
they voted for you to give some
leadership here
it's really important we get the public
consultation involved but
whether a full referendum is necessary
i'd probably question because as i say
you are the elected voice of the people
um one of the big things to me about
this is that it's
um it will be government based on the
functional economic geography there's a
load of
interlinking between our two economies
and the way people sort of live and work
in stratfor and warwick
and the point that councilman crump
raised about the gigafactory we've had
two big announcements this week
um jaguar android's commitment to
guidance their sort of headquarters and
the potential of the gigafactory
coventry airfield now those two things
would both be within the southwestern
ship district they're intrinsically
linked
and surely we should be sort of working
together to maximize the benefit of the
uk economy that we can get out of these
initiatives
rather than sort of inviting between
sort of two district councils about
sort of who's in which area um
i've just got a couple of points just to
conclude really what i wanted to say
i think in terms of the the unitary
debate we
we can't get away from it it's it's in
the background it's it's not survive at
the moment but
if we start giving some thoughts to
start building a council based around
uh functional economic growth we're sort
of setting the agenda and we're ensuring
our residents get represented
rather than perhaps responding to
something that's going to come down to
us when we haven't sort of got
time to respond as effectively as we
might and through that we can sort of
preserve as many services for the
residents as we can so thank you for the
opportunity to make those comments i
hope they've been helpful for you
thank you for clarifying those points
sir mr perks they are indeed very
helpful
um i've got a question from councillor
fielding
[Music]
thank you thank you chair um i'm
i'm very supportive of this concept that
we have got before us
and i'm prepared to propose that we do
it allow it to go forward
uh as um per the cabinet papers
however i would like to see because
there's so much details being raised by
everybody that
we see a timeline where we can sort of
get some
indication of when all these different
aspects
will come forward at the moment we are
talking about a proposal where we don't
know a lot of information the kavanaugh
has got the
the lloyd's papers uh they are very
interesting to read i
succeeded in reading them believe it or
not without going to sleep
um and i really recommend that this goes
forward
to the accounts were meeting
can i just interrupt you here very
quickly we are not making
recommendations
um we are simply scrutinizing hence the
extra meeting
today um but this is this is our
opportunity and we've got councillor
jefferson
and mr buckland with us for them to take
on board our comments as a committee
so it's great to know your support for
this but did you have a question
well the question basically is what sort
of timeline will be
will be agreed so that we can see
different aspects of
the merger taking place thank you very
much council feeding that's
that's actually a really important
aspect of this um i did does that tie in
council for aj with your question about
timelines
uh not not quite have not yet yes okay
but we'll get you in a second then i do
have another question
uh with mike sorry counselor i'm going
to come back to you i just want to see
if there's a response to
the um timeline question from mr
buckland and council jefferson
thank you thank you thank you chair i i
would just point out to pages 64 and 67
on the cabinet agenda because there were
some indicative timelines
included on on that they are the worst
delights and we would have to review
that and come up with their own
timelines ourselves
but it does give an overview of the kind
of high level issues that
need to be considered and the kind of
steps that we need to take
so there
thank you mr buckland council jefferson
i i think um
one of the really good points that
council of fielding makes
is this is about the concept at the
minute
there is an awful lot more work to do i
mean the detail of questions we've had
just demonstrates how much work needs to
be done
and at the moment we're concentrating on
the vision and on the concept and
assuming it gets approval at council
that's when an awful lot of the detailed
work will start
that can actually answer the detailed
questions that people have been
asking thank you council jefferson i'm
also really appreciative that you and
both
yourself brother and mr buckland have
agreed to come in to update over and
scrutiny
um every couple of meetings haven't you
so we know exactly where we're up to
with all of this and have the
opportunity to scrutinize in this way
um counselor fragility uh
thank you chair um with my uh town
council hat on
uh i wondered if we could have the
uh the view of
the leader and and david buckland as to
what impact
will this uh forming of this count new
council have on
uh town and parish councils
um and in addition to that
the in within the timetable that um
[Music]
has been uh published we're talking
about this new council being formed in
may
uh 2024 which i
presume will uh start with some uh
elections uh on new electoral boundaries
um so will that mean then that the
the elections schedule currently
scheduled for 2023
will they go ahead or not go ahead
because it seems
silly to have elections two years
running
it costs money um but once again with my
town council hat on um
the stratfor town council has
elections also scheduled for 2023
um will they still go ahead on their
existing town boundaries
and thereafter to be stitched into the
new boundaries
thank you thank you council fragility a
very interesting question there so i
don't know who wants to go fast because
obviously that's a big consideration
council jefferson um they
uh 2024 uh start date for the new
council
is our working assumption at the moment
and given all the work that needs to be
done and the local government boundary
commission
will actually need to be heavily
involved because it would mean new ward
boundaries
it would mean a close look at the number
of councillors
for the new council so 2024
seems a reasonable start date for the
new council
given the amount of work that needs to
be done that will probably mean that the
elections in 2023 do not for the
district do not go ahead uh
personally i would say no reason why the
town council elections in 2023
couldn't go ahead but i'm not an expert
and i'm not a member of the local
government boundaries commission
as far as the impact on town councils
and
parishes girls i would have thought
initially that they would carry on
as before we've already heard there are
some differences between
the way that parishes operate in
warwick district and the way they
operate in
stratford district whether or not they
are aligned i think would be a matter
for the new council
thank you council jefferson does that
answer your question counselor actually
um wait it does
if town council elections are held in
2023 on the existing boundaries
and a year later those boundaries change
because of
of this uh proposal um
we will have town councils working in in
different different wards from the the
district councils
which doesn't sound right to me but
there you go
chairman i i think as councillor um
jefferson explained we're talking about
as we said many times this afternoon
this morning even so
emerging two districts and and the
impact immediately on the
tanner parish councils would be limited
because they would continue to offer the
services they
currently undertake and the district
councils will continue with that
i think there's more than a fair chance
that if government
approved the may 24 go live dave as
council jefferson said
elections would be held over the
district element of that
now when local government boundary
commission if again if the proposition
gains traction there would have to be a
new local government boundary commission
review for this the wider south balance
shift
that would undoubtedly cause the
exercise that we have currently started
and therefore the new ward boundaries
wouldn't ever come in into place
but when they undertake that exercise
the the boundary commission
do look at existing town and parish
councils in devising new ward boundaries
and therefore that the war boundaries
fought for
stratfor town would be considered
important
an important consideration as part of
that that new
boarding pattern if you like so yeah i
think they wouldn't ignore
what what what the elected members would
be for at the town of paris council
level
thank you mr burkland councillor brady
does that reassure you
yes thank you chair thank you um if i
could just come up with a question
um i have myself so the report proposes
the creation of a steering group of
members comprising
the leader and deputy leader of both
councils and four other councillors of
both councils representing the other
political groups
with formal quarterly reporting of
progress to each respective the cabinet
slash executive my questions are will
these meetings take place in public
or will they be private meetings like
the south warwickshire advisory group
what opportunity will residents and
other members have to contribute to this
group
and will these reports also come to osc
and therefore be subject to proper
public scrutiny
and more generally if the proposals are
agreed how would you like us
as a committee to support and contribute
so number of questions there chairman we
we have their monitoring officer feel
back to number one on the call i wonder
we
are
okay mr grafton welcome to the meeting
hello hello i've been watching and
listening intently thank you
um so so the principal
um idea behind the steering group
of members is to allow
um a safe space for officers
to bring proposals forward to them
um to to discuss we have a sim members
will remember that we had a similar
setup
um when we were working
with cherwell and south south northands
council
and from those group meetings proposals
emerge for business cases
for the um establishment of for example
a legal service and an i.t service
that's not to say that the uh the remit
of
such a group could not change or that
there might be
opportunities for people to contribute
to the discussion
at those meetings or that the the terms
of reference for that
um group might not change and it has to
be said that we
like a lot of this that's been discussed
this morning
the detail around that group has not yet
been established but that
that was my understanding of how that
group would operate
thank you and what support and
contribution would be from osc
um i think it would be um a question
to be raised when we're drawing up those
terms of reference
to to be quite honest with you okay all
right can i just plug up a concern i've
got with your response
um mr grafton i understand it's all in
the future it's a bit of crystal ball
gazing here
but i'm just a little bit concerned that
there's no public
and no opportunity for us for residents
to contribute am i misreading what's
being proposed i i i think if we're just
talking about
this particular group that's in that
recommendation
that was very much around how i
understand it was going to
operate but that's not to say there are
not other
ways in which the public and the osc can
get involved
because obviously we are looking
hopefully as an organization and
hopefully if we
become a super district to pre-decision
scrutiny aren't we so
i am keen to know what the involvement
would be
yeah so so um your pre-decision scrutiny
your your working together with the
cabinet
here and ditto at um warwick with their
executive
would continue as now um and and no
doubt
the leader and the chief executive would
be coming to those meetings
to explain progress on
on the on the development of the
relationship and of course
all those meetings are are open to the
public so the
what i'm saying is that don't look at
that
issue in isolation please from the other
avenues in which the osc and
the public can get involved and be fully
informed about
the progress of the developing
relationship with warwick
thank you uh mr grafton that does
clarify the point for me um
can i just check as well with regards to
the meeting so for example today's
is available to the public if they're
watching now but it's not available on
the website
now we've covered a lot of really
interesting points and we've been very
grateful for the
resource of of our top management team
here
it's a shame that our residents won't
have access to this if they weren't able
to attend because they were at work so
why is it that osc isn't on the
website especially for meetings that
have high public interest such as
has anything to do with a potential
merger i think it's just the way that
um that things have developed over the
last 12 months to be honest with you
if you remember before the pandemic and
the only
um the only meetings that were
were broadcast were those of the
um council cabinet
and planning committees as they were
then we went into lockdown and of course
now all our business
is virtually online i would agree with
you it's time that we reviewed
that practice and whether we should
expand
uh broadcasting of meetings to
other committees one of which probably
the most important would be overview and
scrutiny committee
okay thank you mr grafton that's
reassuring to hear because i think
people are engaging far more now
digitally with
with um committees aren't they which is
great to see
i think we have um a question from
councillor wally hoggins and then if
anybody else has a question please let
me know in the chat i think we're coming
towards the end of our
meeting uh thank you chair um
just to come back to something uh that
mr buckland um
alluded to earlier on um you know
there's a big there's a big group of
people here
that are not residents and that is the
employees really and we'll just focus on
the stratfor district
employees because i want to make sure
that with all of this that that
that they have a voice because there's
nothing worse than having something just
done to you
and having to to go along with it so my
question is around
the following i know that um currently
stratfor district council has a
monitorium
on on recruitment so there are vacant
posts and we we don't advertise to
to fill those posts however the noise
that is not the case
at warwick they're still actively
recruiting um
for for vacancies there so already
stratford employees could view
themselves as being that that
um the poorer of the of the two so
my question is what has this council
done to consult
employees um on the proposed substantial
changes
to their working life please and what
can we do
to make it better and what are we going
to do to make their
the transition for them um easily
more palatable given the fact that there
will be there will be redundancies
and job losses i'm quite sure thank you
chairman if i can respond to that the
first issue in relation to the equipment
freeze yes shortly after
the onset of a pandemic as a management
team
we agreed that we would freeze
improvement apart from
the all but essential positions and we
have done
a limited amount of recruitment last
year we've had a a cctv operator
who was required if we did not recruit
that position that we wouldn't have been
able to
continue with the 24 7 coverage so we
have had some recruitment
but it has been much limited it wasn't
because of
i will say any potential merger at that
point it was just to try and address the
overall
financial position that the council was
probably facing because if you
recall quite early in the pandemic we
were estimating a shortfall of 8.6
million pounds
in the year we we have been fortunate to
receive
several million pounds of government
grants and we did get more car parking
revenue over the summer than we expected
so the short fall on this year has
reduced two and a half million
i've raised this issue though with with
because you're right they don't have a
freezing place at the moment
but they have undertaken to review that
position
if both authorities had
um positively supported the the vision
as we moved forward in relation to staff
that the leader and myself had a a
briefing for staff a couple of three
weeks ago now where
we had 250 staff attend two separate
briefings
where they received the headlines about
what the proposals were and what was
coming for to catalan council
unison though are the the recognized
negotiating body that we have with the
staff side
and as i say we we heard chris and i
chris elliott that is
and myself arranged a joint meeting with
unison to discuss
the proposals and we were presented with
this statement
that they they have they've already met
the two units and branches had met
previously
in which they do support what is being
undertaken here so i think
that that is an important consideration
and i can share
um their joint statement with the
committee if that would be helpful
just to see i mean we would prepare the
whole spiel about
why this was necessary but they repeated
within the statement before we even
started the kind of pressures which are
facing local government at the moment
and and i will say within that their
their position on national um well on
unitary authorities was was noted
as well that they would want to avoid
that across the piece so
i think the vacancies that we now have
online and it was reported just at the
employment of appointments
i think we have 18 vacancies at the
moment would make for
any integration of the teams to be far
less painful than it would have been
otherwise but but the point is
points taken that they haven't had such
a freezer about work
their turnover rates so are generally
slightly higher than at stratford
in any case and we would seek to avoid
redundancies in implementing proposals
but
we've said to both branches and it's
recognized what one of the sweeter
documents that we have coming through
is a joint redundancy policy they may be
inevitable
but the consequence of not doing it
would be far more
local redundancies than if we're working
together
can i just pick up
david said i attended the staff
briefings and i thought it was
unbelievably
impressive that over 250
members of staff turned up to the two
briefings
and i am more than happy and i made it
very clear
that i'm prepared to turn them to any
staff briefing that's needed
thank you council jefferson and that is
reassuring because we are supported by
an incredible team of officers at
stratford district council
so um i thank council wally hogans for
raising that point we have talked today
i've seen you councillor fielding we
have talked today specifically about the
residence but we must also remember the
amazing team of support we have within
stratfor district council
councillor fielding you have a quick
question i understand
yeah so just supporting what the leader
was saying but my question is
can we have a map or plan showing the
boundaries of the two districts i think
it'd be useful for future reference
i see no problem in doing that that
would be very useful actually thank you
um are there any further questions
committee
no thank you so much um to mr buckland
to council jefferson and to
uh george hill and to tony perks and to
phil grafton
and if i've missed anybody out i
apologize that thank you for your time
in coming in today i think we as a
committee have found this incredibly
useful
you'll see we're trying to help with the
grasp of the scrutiny of such a complex
issue for
um but you know for stratfor district
council i think council june has flagged
up a really important point that we do
please ask to be kept informed of the
communication strategy because public
consultation
is top of our priorities as we bring our
residents with us on any change
and we understand that change does
happen especially when you're coming out
of
a challenging pandemic which i think our
organization has met
head on as strongly as anybody could and
we are fully aware as well that you are
up against it with your workloads and
that's why we do thank you for this
extra meeting today
and we look forward to our regular
updates at ovue and scrutiny from both
yourself
um council jefferson and mr buckland but
um we thank you
for your time this morning um liz i
don't believe we have
any urgent business
no chairman thank you well then i will
call this meeting to a close and thank
you all very much for your time
thank you thank you